riding horses can change anything I'm  not who I used to be you've been in  isolation what do you think about that  I'm not good with people  dad oh yeah I just need you to sign this  how long have you been in prison twelve  years and how long from the thought of  the crime to the actual crime  [Music]  split-second  that's a dangerous animal  if you can stay in there for more than  five seconds you're in the program nice  food the whole purpose is to learn how  to break ease wild horses and ultimately  our rehabilitation already I stepped  into an M  she must be a cowboy doctor it covered  up not that bad first time our goal is  to experience empathy that's it easy and  to be open to our faults if you want to  control your horse first you got to  control yourself I've worked with horses  a long time  some you can break some you can't there  you go  I was a kid and you left me alone was an  accident even riding horses can change  anything  I'm not who I used to be  [Music]  you